حجزت مقعدها بجانب زوجها في رحله الموت
التي تاجلت مرارا وحين جاء الموعد المنتظر
منحته لابنها سليمان ليرافق ابيه على متن
الغواصه تايتان في اخر رحله لهما لقد كنت
سعيده لاجلهما تعانقنا وضحكنا لان شهر زاد
كان كطفل صغير في حماسه للذهاب الى الرحله
بهذه الكلمات وبغصه وحرقه تملاان قلب ام
وزوجه مفجوعه روت كريستين داود زوجه رجل
الاعمال الباكستاني شاهد في مقابله
تلفزيونيه تفاصيل اخر لقاء لها مع زوجها
وابنها اللذين توفيا في حادث الغواصه
كريستين قالت انه كان من المفترض ان ترافق
زوجها في الرحله لكنها تراجعت مقابل رغبه
ابنها سليمان ابن التاسعه عشره في خوض
المغامره وتحطيم رقم قياسي لكن وبدلا من
ذلك كتب له الموت على متن تلك الغواصه